yeah like relationships aren't good if
you're keeping score of what he's doing
for you and what you're doing for him
yeah to be natural
I'm curious from the girls okay would
you rather date a guy you don't or this
is for a lifetime okay one guy you don't
really like so yeah I don't know think
of the last guy you dated that you just
you're kind of into him kind of not
everyone got someone in their head okay
now now I mean you're thinking of
something
or the guy you liked the most so the guy
you're the most in love with would do
anything yeah I got him in your head now
would you rather share the guy you liked
the most ever and this sort of maybe not
as you know maybe it's not his job to
screw other girls but every now and then
he's gonna get some strange but you're
the main you're the main
or stay with the guy that you eh kind of
liked for life kind of liked
can I just say something I won't share
the guy that I like the most but I'll
share the guide that I don't like the
most so if I like you that much I want
you to be mine if I don't like you I'm
happy to yeah if you provide for me we
have an agreement there you go go do
whatever you want I don't give two F's
okay what about you I mean I'd rather
just stay single but if I had to pick
one it'd probably be the guy that I
don't really like because if I really
like someone I am jealous and I am Petty
as well and I will do the most if I like
you and you're not mine do you know what
I'm saying
okay what about you it's a difficult one
because if you're living with someone
that you don't like you're going to be
very miserable and very unhappy so would
you rather just build yourself to a
confidence where you don't mind and and
like I see she's so confident and she's
happy I would rather be with someone
that I love and be happy so but but my
do you guys think the most men cheat or
no yeah yeah depends where you come get
him so why would it be different with
you like in your case would be like oh
my guy wants it's gonna change for me
it's the same thing it's just the
respect you know I definitely it's the
respect I salute you so and I think
you're like I can sense you guys are
both are great people you know and
you're like really subtle sure of you
who you are and it takes a lot of work
to do that but there is also a red line
I think that just boundaries if you want
to create children healthy relationship
because it's easier you have to work way
harder than I have to work I'm like I
know my boundaries he knows his
boundaries things might slip out of
balance we just like forgive forget blah
blah blah work them out but the work
that you both have to do and maybe
you're naturally ignite can sense that
you naturally are not jealous person you
know you naturally are way more
open-minded than a lot of women but she
must have met him doing that yes but I
think also in the future when you have
kids things might get out of balance
it's harder work I think you know if you
just see relationship traditional
relationship the most successful
relationship was just stay with your
woman if you cheated don't ever let her
know same if she if she I tried that I
tried at the beginning right yeah and
there was like times where like she came
over and like there was she came over
early or maybe not even early but I was
like sloppy and she like arrived and I
was with a girl yeah and it's like giant
fight right but we keep we keep like the
emotional stuff like segmented yeah like
the love and the affection ourselves
just with her yeah
how much longer the world will be normal
but no I mean we're pretty happy with
the three dogs we have it still allows
flexibility to travel and do all this
yeah it's interesting I'm curious
because you guys gonna get older there's
there is like a reduce of your sexual
means you probably won't even need to
have as much
yeah but I but I take like supplemental
testosterone to an endocrinologist I
still take like Maca and the different
libido supplements my point is if that
is what brings you feel mint right right
now at this point what would bring you
the film in the future
I don't know I mean like I come from an
interesting background like the reason
why I went and slept with 1600 girls
like I came from like a pretty verbal
abusive childhood where like my parents
are really nice people but they're
always saying like you're going to be
nothing you're going to be a failure
you're going to be this like that and
when I like sleep with a new girl it
makes me like feel like oh I'm not like
that yeah
I don't know if it's compensating but
it's it's definitely like but you know I
wouldn't have gone and done this had I
not come from that background like
people like a lot of like the best UFC
fighters they're bullied for instance as
a kid and they were like I'm gonna
become the best fighter in the world so
like I think my mom like stripped all
the like validation for me like
routinely over over all those people
come back is to sleep with women too
make up for that trauma yeah what would
you
all right cool cool the client I'm a guy
I come to you and I say to you right I
sleep with
I don't know eight women a week right
I've been doing it for years years but
now I'm ready to commit to one woman
what advice would you give me
I go from from seeing much of people
just to one because that's obviously
helping me that's helping my confidence
and that's fulfilling so how would you
say to me cool
stop that stick to one woman and this is
how you can what why wouldn't I don't I
don't ever tell them like you know you
should just be doing this but you know I
don't tell them like any societal
narratives I don't tell guys to get a
girlfriend or wife or bang a bunch of
girls or see a bunch of girls inside I
want to be with what women how can I go
about
that would you even give them advice
lots of lots of guys just want
girlfriends but but most of them like in
practice like once I teach them to be
able to have a bunch of options and they
pick the best one usually and get more
serious with that one but you know if
they had that issue where they were
seeing a bunch
I would you know they have to like
realign their internal values and stuff
like that I guess but they wouldn't even
want to do that I don't think do you
guys who here out of the women thinks
that all men cheat when given the chance
you know what I would have to say I
discovered something new tonight
completely because she's stunning
gorgeous right and a lot of women that
get cheated on they will just say I'm
out of shape I'm I'm less but it's just
I'm realizing your looks and who you are
won't stop men cheating and wanting tips
I wanna I wanna just get this all right
you think yes I hope raise your hand if
you think yes all men cheat when given
the chance
yeah okay so
um three girls I'm just curious so NBA
players have women and I know this um I
just interviewed a guy who he has like
good friends with a couple professional
sports players right and he said that on
the sidelines these girls
that are tens okay nines and tens will
come to their games and just offer them
threesomes and say like we're available
and they hunt them down and try to get
them to cheat on their wives
what do you guys do you think those guys
Mo that most guys would cheat in that
situation
if he's a man of God then it's very
unlikely that's what I was going to say
as well yeah that's gonna say the same
thing that's just a fear of hell right
no no it's not
it's not it's not fear of hell I think
men and women
men and women yeah of course I think
that's delusional honestly I know some
pretty religious dudes but like it's
very unlikely but if you're telling me
at 10. like most of these religious guys
would say they would never do it have
never been in that City wait can I just
say yeah also just because someone says
they are religious does not mean they
are religious someone can say they are
10 out of 10 religious like you said you
know religious people but that doesn't
actually mean they're religious same way
you can go to church doesn't mean you're
a Christian just because you go to
church what is religious
I think that's so relevant it's
different for everyone it could me
personally I can't say because I'm
actually not religious but I could ask
you and I could ask you and you could
both give me two completely different
answers that could both be correct but
but I'm saying that my point is even
religious guys if they're in that if
they're in a situation where tens are
hunting them down Tans they're gonna
religious I read religious people are
more likely to commit our
a statistical one well I don't know
about that but all I know is that
because they're
like well
um we had a conversation before about
church guys and dating Church guys or
people that are religious because
they're around such like Purity for that
it's like that's like another world like
oh I want to try that yeah look at the
priests right in the Catholic Church
exactly that yeah I think religion is no
guarantee for not cheating yeah at all
um I'm not it's less likely though as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible